situation began to develop as it did I
directed my National Security team to
monitor closely and report to me hour by
hour
I instructed them to prepare for a range
of scenarios I also convened our key
allies on on a zoom call to make sure
we're all on the same page it's critical
that we're in a coordinated in our
response and coordinated in what we to
anticipate we agree they agreed with me
that we had to make sure we gave Putin
no excuse let me emphasize the gay Putin
no excuse to blame this on the west or
to blame this on NATO
we made clear that we were not involved
we had nothing to do with it this was
part of a struggle within the Russian
system